my interest has been to probe the nature
of erotic desire and in long-term
relationships but also in general and to
see where love and desire relate but
also conflict because therein lies the
mystery of eroticism and in particular
because of the profound change that
sexuality has experienced in the context
of committed relationships which for
most of history was about procreation
and about a woman's marital duty but not
anchored rooted in this concept called
desire which is to own the wanting which
is so much a part of an individualistic
culture in which there is an i who
deserves to want and who is entitled to
have their ones be met we would like to
think that people are having affairs
today but in fact people have had
adultery from the day marriage was
invented in fact if there wouldn't be a
taboo if there wasn't a measurable
threat and the metal threat is human
nature you know it is the only
commandment that is repeated twice in
the Bible once for doing it and once
just for thinking about it so there is
nothing new about the act of
transgression itself what is very new is
the meaning of that act and the context
in which it takes place because marriage
has undergone a fundamental change in
structure and in meaning and
particularly in longevity and when I say
marriage I mean all forms of committed
coupledom so in our time people stray
for a multitude of reasons they may
stray because of their discontent
because of their loneliness because of
their lack of affirmation because of
their disconnect in their relationship
because life is short and they are in
touch with mortality or because they are
on the other side of it which is a
certain sense of permission and
entitlement to all experiences that are
affirming actualizing amplifying
and for which we have received
tremendous push we deserve to be happy
you know we brought happiness down from
the heavens where it used to be part of
the afterlife and it is no longer just a
possibility but it's a mandate so in the
name of being happier and we find that
we deserve to go and explore too often
look not necessarily for another partner
certainly in the context of happy
couples or couples who are relatively
content and who also experience affairs
and infidelity but a search for the
other self a search for the person that
is not the one that we have become over
the many years a search for
gratification a search for sexual
expressiveness loads of reasons that
unfortunately are not often part of the
negotiation certainly into history
sexual couples so they become part of
the most traditional model that
coupledom has ever known which is
proclaimed monogamy and clandestine
adultery but I think it's very dissing
what we call a traditional marriage if
we're going back to just the 60s or the
50s that is very very short time for
most of history marriage has been an
economic institution it was for
companionship for family life for social
status and for economic reasons land
expansion and so forth and we brought
love to marriage then we brought
sexuality to love then we brought a
connection between marital happiness and
sexual satisfaction all courtesy of the
democratization of contraception the
women's movement and the gay movement
what we may call traditional marriage to
me is that form of marriage in which by
the way the adulterous space for most of
history was the space for love because
well love was not a building block nor a
foundation nor a motive for being
married what we have done by making in
the romantic ideal
by making love the central ingredient
I'm chosen you choose me it's a free
choice Enterprise we are going to
cultivate this wonderful intimacy which
is no longer the traditional living
together working the land raising the
kids and all the vicissitudes of the
everyday but
intimacy as intimacy and I'm going to
have this communicative experience with
you where I'm going to share my most
valuable assets which is not my land but
my internal life my feelings my worries
my dreams my aspirations and you're
going to reflect back on me and you're
going to validate me and in our
relationship I'm going to learn to
transcend my existential aloneness
because the couple has become the
bulwark the safe-haven against all the
insecurities away from a much larger
community in which people had their
needs met by a large Network and the
couple was one interaction but not the
central interaction the organizing
principle of our mythic and practical
life that today is the new marriage I
would say
you